it's the perfect day you know what I'm
talking about it's the perfect day to
just go outside and do stuff with your
friends or friend your human friend your
animal friend it doesn't really matter
doesn't my friend the shabby is an
African sulcata tortoise but she's from
Southern California which is funny
sometimes if one of us is feeling blue
we'll just go to the park and well hey
we decided to try yoga for the first
time so we found some mats and we got
our downward dog on or at least tried to
I mean I tried to I don't think shabby
was feeling it too much after working up
an appetite I got us a croissant from a
cafe I wasn't too into it though and I
don't think shabby was either so we went
ahead and we just fed it to one of the
local ducks between you and me I think
shabby has something against ducks but I
think they're fine so whatever sometimes
in friendship there's these differences
that you discover about each other they
could seem a little bit irreconcilable
at one point Chevy's lack of interest in
some of the things we were doing just
got me so heated that I just I just
split and went and chilled with some of
the birds at the park her I tried to but
none of them seemed to want to build a
friendship with me that's cool that's
it's totally fun luckily true friends
take you back even after you've thrown a
fit and it's a good thing because when
you had the perfect day you know there
can be no catch there's only love and
that's more than enough
I get that I'm not cut out for everyone
which is probably why my only friend is
a tortoise who can't hear me